(Water splashes)
(Footsteps crunching)
- Good morning, I hope
you're having an amazing day,
it's Mark Wiens.
I'm in Batticaloa, on the
east coast of Sri Lanka.
This is a beautiful city, it's
so quiet, it's so peaceful.
It's known for it's lagoons,
and for lunch, we have been
invited to the Sri Lankan
army camp.
So we're gonna be eating and experience
Sri Lankan army mess hall food,
which is gonna be a totally
new experience for me.
Then after that, we're gonna
go straight to someone's home,
who's gonna cook us some
fresh lagoon seafood.
I think some crab, some
fish, that's gonna be
seafood from the lagoon.
We're getting started
right now, and I can't wait
to share all the food
with you in this video.
(upbeat music)
(footsteps crunching)
- Good morning Ruzaina.
- Good morning! (laughs)
- We're getting started, but
a slight, slight complication
before we....
We head out.
(engine revs)
(speaks in foreign language)
- We are on our way, we
are taking the rescue van.
(laughter)
(footsteps on crunching)
(waves crashing on shore)
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Mark] As we're driving into the city,
we just stopped along the beach,
because there's a crowd of fishermen
who are pulling in the nets.
They just pulled in a
net, the net is full.
They're like little ... anchovies?
Like anchovies, yeah?
- [Ruzaina] Yeah.
- [Mark] Little, small fish,
but the waves are crashing.
It takes like, ten men to pull in the net
cause it's so full.
They're so fresh, they're just sparkling,
shimmering in that sunlight.
This is a beautiful, beautiful setting.
It's so clean, it's so fresh.
(waves crashing)
- [Mark] And then they go into the sea
to wash off the fish,
making sure they don't
lose their balance on those waves.
(waves crashing)
(footsteps crunching)
- Back in the van, we're on our way.
(car engine roars)
(upbeat music)
(chopping)
- [Mark] We are on the Sri
Lankan special forces base.
In the kitchen now, of the mess hall.
This is where they do the cooking.
This is where they're
cooking for the entire camp.
(pot lid banging)
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Mark] Over on this side of the kitchen,
they are making rice in
a huge pan, Over fire.
It's steaming away, that steam just
puffed out of there.
They're burning both
a combination of wood,
as well as dry coconut husk.
(crunching)
(bubbling)
(chopping)
- Okay, hopefully that
chair doesn't collapse
in. under my weight.
Okay. But as they are
cooking, as they're preparing
this meal for the mess
hall, for the entire unit,
I just wanna quickly
explain a little bit about
what's going on.
We have been invited to the
Sri Lankan Special Forces unit.
The Sri Lankan Forces played a huge role
in Sri Lanka.
They're very well respected.
And just a background of Sri Lanka.
It's been through times of war,
it suffered from many
natural disasters, tsunamis.
Then the Special Forces
were actually created
during the war.
And they helped create peace.
And then in times of natural
disaster, like the tsunamis,
they've been there to help,
to help Sri Lanka recover,
to rebuild the roads, the bridges.
They've been in charge of
some of the biggest, like,
some of the hardest projects in Sri Lanka.
This unit of the Sri Lankan Special Forces
has been in charge.
We're not gonna be able to
see the entire compound,
but they have allowed us, graciously,
to come into the kitchen
to watch a little bit
of the cooking and then to eat
Sri Lankan Special Forces food.
All of the chefs, everyone
cooking, they're all officers
of the Special Forces.
And they're all working
together, each handling a task
in the kitchen.
(oil sizzling)
- [Mark] He just heated up some oil
and dropped in some lagoon fish
that's also gonna be
for lunch. Gonna try it.
Looks like it's marinated in a mixture.
Looks like some turmeric, maybe some
curry powder on there already.
(pounding)
(chopping)
I'm just hanging out, as they're
still frying the fish, ...
having a cup of tea.
And then they're also still
chopping up tons of vegetables.
And the officer is also
helping us to arrange
a fish for the next meal.
So we're talking on the
phone and we're trying
to organize a fish.
Not sure if it's gonna be a lagoon fish,
which would be a brackish water fish,
salt and freshwater, or
a straight ocean fish.
But yeah, there's lots of
amazing fish in Batticaloa.
(car lock beeps)
- [Mark] You know how some days,
everything goes according to plan,
but other days, you just kinda, like,
things don't work out
quite as you thought they
were gonna work out, but
it's still an amazing
adventure in the process?
Today is one of those days.
(upbeat music)
(speaking in foreign language)
- Hello, hello.
- Hi, hello.
- [Mark] How are you? How are you?
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Mark] What's up, man?
- [Mark] Thank you, thank you very much.
Nice to meet you.
(laughter)
- Okay, so we took a little drive.
- Sri Lanka.
(laughs)
One of the, one of the
officers, this is like a-
- I want to this see, ah.
- Are you the fisherman?
- No, no, no, no.
- [Mark] Okay.
- I am a ...
(speaks foreign language)
- Oh god, it's a huge.
- [Mark] Nine kilo?
- [Man] Nine kilo.
- Omega three, yeah?
- [Mark] Omega three?
- Yeah
- As we were at the
Special Forces unit base,
the officer called one
of his, like, fishermen,
and they had a special catch for the day,
which he said was the number one fish.
He said it was his favorite fish.
And so, plans sort of changed.
We ended up in a complete
random adventure.
And-
(rickshaw engine revs)
- Vehicle shift, and another
slight change of plans.
The van is heading back to the hotel
to pull out the van again.
Still sorting out that situation,
but we are in a rickshaw,
we're heading back to base camp,
where we are gonna cook.
(upbeat music)
- [Mark] One of the beautiful
things about this region of
Sri Lanka are the lagoons.
Which are, just, you feel
like you're on a series of
islands, because you
just keep hopping from
over lagoons and onto
little pieces of land
that are carved out by lagoons.
(upbeat music)
(beeping)
- [Mark] Ahh, okay.
- Mora, singularly, we call mora.
- Mora?
- Yes.
- Mora.
- [Mark] You like to eat?
- Oh, yeah, why not,
why not? All the time.
(laughter)
- Not only me, but all the people.
- Okay.
- [Mark] Shark is quite
common in Sri Lanka,
and throughout Asia.
But one of the thing that
it's just worth noting,
that the entire shark
is going to be consumed.
Not just a piece of it,
not just a part of it,
but the entire, the entirety of the shark.
(water splashing)
(cracking)
(machine whirring loudly)
- [Mark] They're gonna make curry shark,
so he just cracked open about 10 coconuts.
But then they have their own grinder.
That's the importance.
That's how prevalent coconut milk
and shredded coconut
are in Sri Lankan food.
(knife slicing across wood)
(crinkling)
- [Mark] And they're preparing
all the other ingredients
for the curry.
(rapid chopping)
- Oh, two different types of tomato.
Oh yeah.
(chopping)
(slow soft pounding)
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Mark] Thank you.
(Water splashing)
- [Mark] I love how they're not taking
any shortcuts, even for 50 people,
freshly squeezed, handmade coconut milk.
And that's gonna go into the curry.
(water splashing)
(chopping)
(pounding)
- [Mark] Sri Lanka has some
of the world's best cinnamon,
and I love what they do,
they take the cinnamon bark
and just pound it fresh, so you release,
you can smell that aroma just released.
He's taking it out of
the mortar right now,
onto the spice pile.
The cinnamon, the curry leaves,
the chilies, the onions,
the garlic.
Oh, yeah.
And I love how he just, like,
doesn't skin the garlic.
Keeps the skin on, just
hacks the entire thing up.
(thudding)
(scrapping)
- [Mark] He just dumped
in all of that spices
and all those onions and
tomatoes that he chopped up.
And so it's like, mixed
before the fire is even on.
(upbeat music)
(water splashing)
(swishing)
- [Mark] Then he added in,
actually there's a first batch
of coconut milk, which is
the thick coconut cream,
but he first added in
like the coconut milk,
which is less, it's more watery.
And I've just been talking to them,
they said that this fish...
Oh, this move is the
best; this stirring move.
It's called the pot, the pot swirl.
No, I just made that up.
Just talking about the shark meat,
and in Sri Lanka, it's
also very common to eat,
especially when you're a
mother, when you are expecting,
or when you're nursing,
because of the nutrients,
because of the, they say it's
very high in omega threes.
(speaking in foreign language)
(sizzling)
(metal clanking)
It is smelling so good right now.
You really smell the curry leaves,
you smell the, he added in
a lot of turmeric in there,
the fresh chilies.
(upbeat music)
(loud thuds)
(water splashing)
(swishing)
- [Mark] He just added
in the coconut cream,
the thicker coconut, the first squeeze,
so that's gonna be richer.
It means they must be getting close.
(upbeat music)
(water splashing)
- [Mark] Let's eat.
(laughter)
(upbeat music)
- [Mark] And we're gonna move over because
we've been invited to eat
over with the officers.
- Sorry?
- We are gonna go to
the other house to eat?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Okay.
(child exclaims)
- [Mark] Oh, nice. Okay.
I have good light in here.
(thud)
- [Mark] We are now sitting down to eat,
all the food is ready, all
the food that they prepared.
The rice, which they fried actually,
then there's a bunch of
... there's a shrimp curry,
there's dal, there's,
oh, that one is the fish.
- [Woman] Fish fry.
- [Mark] Oh, fish fry there.
- [Mark] So this was all
the normal food that they
ate, right?
- [Mark] And then this is the extra.
(child whimpers)
(upbeat music)
(child babbling)
(coughing)
- [Mark] Quick wash. Wash of the hands.
(water splashing)
Ah, and unlike any other Sri Lankan food
so far that I've had.
Oh, I've gotta try some of that.
Oh, the shark feels so incredibly tender.
Okay, I'm gonna add on
a little more gravy.
But wow, the shark.
That's like a shark steak.
Look at, oh, that just
completely almost disintegrates,
it's so soft.
Mix it with the rice.
(laughs)
Oh, wow. The shark is amazing.
(laughing)
- It's like, it's so incredibly tender.
It's almost like, and
it's like, chicken breast,
in its like, leanness.
But so ... that curry is amazing too.
A little bit spicy, you can taste the
coconut cream in there.
All of the dishes would be typical.
It's what everybody ate today,
for lunch, in the mess hall,
except for the extra special dish.
I'm gonna try some of the shrimp.
You can see there's Moringa
leaves in it, I believe.
And you can see it, it's
like totally different,
it's like full of greenery.
Oh, wow.
Yeah, that is stunning.
It's like, mmmmm.
You taste the Moringa
leaves, you taste like a
bitterness in it.
And then, I like how it's kinda watery,
and not like rich, but very spicious.
This one was a fried lagoon fish,
which then cooked in onions
and more curry leaves
and fried it now.
How is the food?
- Nice.
(upbeat music)
- Everything is so superbly spiced, like,
even the dal, even the potatoes.
Mmmm.
It's all like, yeah, vibrant,
a beautiful mixture of spices,
it's amazing food.
- I'm shocked at the
shark. It's so tender.
- [Mark] It's so tender!
- Yeah, it's like,
super soft. Dreamy soft.
- [Mark] Way, way more tender.
It's like chicken breast
in (mumbles) but like...
- I know, I know.
- [Mark] absorbed in all that flavor.
- And it's so tasty, right?
- [Mark] Potatoes.
(upbeat music )
- [Mark] Those potatoes are
incredible, they're so creamy.
And again, like the curry
leaves, the chili. Wow.
(upbeat music)
Mmmm. Mmmm.
- [Mark] Too good to resist.
Alright. Gotta mix up everything again.
What a meal.
(Car engine softly roars)
- [Mark] It's getting very late very fast,
but we have one more
meal that was actually
scheduled earlier, but then,
the adventure took place,
so we're on our way there
now, to eat another meal.
And this is gonna be really
local, especially Batticaloa...
regional specialty dishes.
(upbeat music)
(high pitched ringing)
- [Mark] This is where
we're gonna have our
second meal.
This is where the aunties have prepared us
a very local Batticaloa meal.
(speaks in foreign language)
- [Mark] Oh, awesome.
(speaking in foreign language)
(laughing)
- [Mark] I think she's already prepared
because we got here so
late, she's already prepared
some of the curries, some of the dishes,
but she's gonna make
for us string hoppers,
which are like the noodle,
rice noodle curl ups.
And to with the curries, cause
that's especially common,
and especially in the morning,
and at night for dinner.
- [Ruzaina] So, this is
something from this area.
- [Woman] Yeah, some coconut. Coconut-
- [Mark] Coconut milk?
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Mark] There's like half a dozen dishes.
The fire is going, the wood fire.
- Good, really good.
(laughing)
(upbeat music)
(scraping)
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Mark] Everything is prepared,
but then she's just dishing everything out
but her expertise, her experience.
- [Mark] Oh!
Oh, that entire steamer is
filled with string hoppers.
I didn't know, I thought
the water was just boiling,
but that was already full
by the time we got here.
- [Mark] Invited us into their home,
into their living room,
we're sitting on a mat.
It's beautiful food,
the colors, the display,
everything dished out, the string hoppers.
And we're getting ready to dig in.
You just asked the question, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] About this dish, right?
- [Mark] And what it is, it's
like, it's a coconut milk,
it looks like a coconut milk boil.
And what is the local name of it?
Pole...
- [Ruzaina] Pole Pala.
- Pole pala
- [Mark] But then we didn't
know what the english name is so
we just asked and it's
'Mountain nut leaves'?
- [Ruzaina] Mountain nut grass.
- Mountain nut grass?
(laughter)
that is kind of a funny name (laughs).
- [Ruzaina] Start with this
- [Mark] Gonna get started
here with the Rasam and you,
and it's typical to just drink it.
You can drink it from
the bowl, it's a soup.
Ah Tamil, especially Taimil influence?
- [Ruzaina] Yes
(child babbling)
- Oh wow!
(laughs) oh that's amazing!
(laughs) I wasn't even
expecting that much flavor.
It is so incredibly good!
It's like, it's slighting rich
and oily but like refreshing
and sour at the same time.
Oh what is that sourness coming from?
- [Ruzaina] Tamarind
- Tamarind, okay!
Oh that beautiful!
(upbeat music)
- [Mark] That's spectacular.
A little bit of everything
on the plate with
the String Hoppers, in it
all with the soups and sauces
over the String Hoppers, the coconuts.
I guess I'll try the, what is it called?
The Mountian...
- [Ruzaina] Nut Grass.
- [Mark] Nut Grass.
- [Ruzaina] (laughs) Not
nut, Mountain Knotgrass.
- [Mark] Oh, Mountain 'not' Grass?
- [Ruzaina] (laughs) Knotgrass
- [Mark] (laughs) Really?
- [Ruzaina] Knot, like a knot.
- [Mark] N-O-T ?
Oh!
(laughter)
okay, let me just clarify that.
It's not 'Mountian Nut Grass'.
Mountain Knot, 'K', K-N-O-T.
Mountain.
Let's call it Mountain K-not
(laughter)
- [Mark] Okay, Mountain Knotgrass
wrapped in coconut milk.
It almost has the feel of
Sage, that kind of like...
- [Ruzaina] Feel?
- [Mark] Fealty, fealty feel.
(child babbling and shuffling)
(muffled thud)
mmmh.
Oh wow, that's spectacular.
- [Mark] It has like a,
almost like a cloth texture.
Really nutty taste; wrapped
up in that coconut milk.
Oh, that's spectacular.
It's like Spinach taste
but with like a totally
different texture.
- [Mark] Moving over to the
lagoon fish, and this is in
a curry.
I'll grab some of the
Hoppers, String Hoppers.
- Mmh
- Mmmmh!
oh the fish!
- Mmh
- There's some kind of really
unique green taste to it.
- Yeah, it's lagoon fish, right?
So you get that lagoon taste.
- That's what it is?
- (laughs) Yeah.
- (mumbles)
- Yeah.
- [Mark] It's almost like a
vegetable taste in the fish.
- [Ruzaina] Yeah.
- [Mark] And the curry
is also really Cuminy.
- Yes.
- Really Cuminy, yeah.
- [Mark] And then the String
Hoppers are really nice and
light.
- [Ruzaina] Mmh.
- [Mark] Like it's like
a lighter form of rice.
Like Vermicelli, almost,
but even, like, lighter.
- It is made with Rice flour.
- [Mark] Going back in for some of the,
the Mountian K-not,...
(Ruzaina laughs)
Mountain Knotgrass, and then
mix it with some of the more
coconut as well.
Mmmh, mmh, the mix of herbs
and vegetables is like...
- So awesome right?
- It's so awesome.
It's so good, it's so vibrant!
- But you will not get this all over...
- Okay.
- This kind of , this is like
a very very special dish.
- Only Batticaloa, or all over east coast?
- I've had it only in Batticaloa;
you might get it elsewhere
but I've never ever ever, in
my life, come across something
like this.
It's here that I had.
- Ahh okay.
- Yeah, It's here that I had.
- And in Colombo, can you find it? No?
- No
- Colombo no.
- Nobody makes it like this.
- Okay.
- So basically, it's
like Mountain K-notgrass
(laughter)
right?
- That's what we'll call it (laughs)
- It's cooked in coconut
milk and chilies and...
You have to taste it.
It doesn't look as
appetizing, as you can see
- That really is the dish of the meal.
- [Ruzaina] It doesn't look as appetizing.
It just looks so watery and
someone looking at it wouldn't
even realize that it has so much flavor.
- [Mark] It's that vegetable
that's providing so much flavor
- [Ruzaina] Yeah.
(upbeat music)
- They are fishing right behind
me, but we just made it back
to the hotel where we
started this entire day.
It's been a spontaneous day;
it's been an adventurous day.
It's been a day that didn't go as planned,
and it was an amazing day.
I want to say a massive Thank
you to Ruzaina, she's The
'Minority Taste.'
She makes videos.
I'll have all her links in
the description box bellow.
She arranged everything,
she took us around.
Thank you, Ruzaina.
And thank you to everyone
else who showed us
amazing hospitality.
I am loving the East coast of Sri Lanka.
That's gonna be it for this
video but if you haven't watched
the entire Sri Lanka series,
be sure to check it all out.
I'll have the link in the
description box, watch
all the videos, all the amazing food.
And I want so say a big thank
you for watching this video.
Please remember to give it a
thumbs up, if you enjoyed it.
Leave a comment bellow, I'd
love to hear from you and if
you're not already
subscribed, click 'Subscribe',
and also click that little bell icon,
that way you'll get notified
of the next video that
I publish.
Good night from Batticaloa,
see you on the next video.
Thanks, again, for watching.